بعد 20 يوم من الحجز رحت على
ال على الفندق وغيرت تاريخ الحجز الفرح
خليته
[موسيقى]
15 كان فرحنا يوم 510 يوم الخميس فاخذنا
كم يوم في الفندق يعني ننام
فيه قضينا يوم الجمعه ام اي يوم السبت قوم
معاز معاز معاز قوم اصحى ايش اسمع الصوت
صوت صواريخ صوت انفجارات وما حدا يعني ما
كناش فاهمين شي يعني ورحنا يعني باتجاه
البيت قضينا تقريبا يومين يومين تمام
يومين بس بالبيت بعد ثلاث ايام اليوم
الثالث الساعه يمكن 6ه الصبح كنا نايمين
فصار انفجار كثير هيك عالي في في المنطقه
اللي صار شويه انا بقول لها يعني انه زيهم
زي ه الانفجارات كل الموجود يعني الساعه
خسه العصر سمعت انا صوت ازعاج وصراخك في
الحاره بطلع ايش في قالوا هددوا العماره
هذه وكذا بقول عم اكيد قال اتصلوا على
فلان والحقوا طيب نزلنا على في عننا احنا
تحت البيت يعني في بدره نزلنا عليه كلنا
خلال ع دقائق تم قصف العماره طوابق على
الارض ركام كامل انصدمت من كل شي حوالي
صرت يعني اطلع اتاكد اذا اثاث البيت
والاشياء كل شيء في البيت كنا مخططين
ومرتبين له ورسمين ورسم فانا ما بدي ولا
ولا اي خدش تصير فصرت اطلع حوالي الحيطه
نصين التلفزيون
مقلوب شغلات كثير هيك
واقعه مكسره يوم ما شفت ال هيك كل شيء
مكسر كل الدنيا حوالي غبره ووسخ خصوصا انه
يعني بيتي كله فوات ف فجاه لقيته كل شيء
اسود كل شيء مكسر كل شيء على الارض فهو
هذا اكثر يوم يعني لانه ما لحقت افرح ما
لحقت اقعد في بيتي ما لحقت اقعد على كنابي
او اقعد مرتاحه ما لحقت حتى بحكي له انا
بس بتفرج على البيت بالصور ما لحقت احفظ
مع يعني ما لحق مخي يحفظ معالم البيت او
كل شيء فيه وتحركت انا واياها ورحنا يعني
باتجاه الجنوب وصلنا على بيت خالي في دير
البلح ايش كان بيستنانا احنا ماشي حرمين
ومخدتي لانه عرسان ها كل هذا لشانه نحنا
[موسيقى]
عرسان بلش يومك يا دينا حاليا الروح يعني
اول شيء الفطور بس بما اني شاطره والمطبخ
فانا متوليه موضوع الغداء طبعا تحت
تعليمات حماتي لاني مطبخ طبخات يعني عمري
ما تصورت ان انا حا اطبخها بهذا العمر او
حتى كميات ح طبخها
لانه احنا في البيت خمس اشخاص وانا متعوده
اطبخ يعني يعني على قد خمس اشخاص بس مش 15
شخص او 20 شخص انا بس بحب اعجن وبتقل معهم
الاش قبل تقاتل مع انهم بقولوا لي انك
بترق صواريخ يعني صواريخ يعني انه ال
العجنه هيك الرغيف بكون ممطوط يعني مع انه
لا انا باكد لهم دائما انه لا التخصص ما
نقيش بدينا يمكن اكثر يمكن ماسك موضوع ال
العج مطبخ يعني كان بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
يعني ايش اكثر شيء بتتمنيه بحياتك نرجع لخ
ع عن جد او يعني اصحى الاقي هذا كانه
كابوس وبس بدي اصحى منه ونرجع ونلاقي كل
شيء زي ما كان احنا اصلا يعني انا كنت
حاجز تاريخ الفرح في 1310 ام تمام
و يعني دينا استنت علي لما زهقت 20
ي بدك تغير التاريخ بدك تغير
التاريخ خلص قلبي ما كان م بعد 20 يوم من
الحجز رحت
على على الفندق وغيرت تاريخ الحجز الفرح
خليته خم
[موسيقى]
عش
ه